hi chloe it's so nice to see you
um
first of all out of the whole cast
which two would you love to go on a road
trip with
um definitely wednesday for sure i think
you know even if i wasn't playing her i
would say that for sure and morticia you
know what i mean i think morticia is
always been one of my favorite
characters and their relationship is so
funny and i just think
i would i would die to meet this person
who would be your number one road trip
song because i know the soundtrack has
like snoop dogg megan the stallion
there's so many great records so um who
would be your favorite i mean uh out of
the music in the film
sure or any song or any song yeah
probably i mean with the two of them in
the car i'd probably have to play the
season of the witch you know what i mean
i feel like it's a little bit
low-hanging fruit but i'm gonna pick it
and i'm gonna play it you know what i
mean
would you say getting back into this
character during the pandemic really was
like therapeutic for you
for sure you know i felt i felt really
lucky to be working during the pandemic
you know i think it you know in a time
when there was there's so much hardship
and there's still so is so much hardship
and ripple effect from you know
quarantine and and all this being in
lockdown for that amount of time yeah
i felt really really blessed and super
lucky to be able to have the chance to
be creative and and to have a little
reprieve from the amount of you know
intense stress that we were all under at
that point in time so i felt so blessed
and so lucky and uh you know who better
to jump into than wednesday adam's shoes
um having played wednesday twice you
know what trait sticks out and what do
you love most about her
i love that she is always 10 steps ahead
of people you know she's
she's the adult in the family in a weird
way you know i think when she gives her
mother permission to find other men
because she thinks her father's dying
it's like what
like what are you even you're talking to
your mother about this and she's like
trying to school her mother um i think
he's you know she's just super confident
um and she's super relaxed about it and
uh she's just a really smart girl she's
fun i love that did you get a chance to
zoom charlize or oscar was there a wrap
party on zoom
yeah right uh no i mean sadly you know
the thing with um with animation as
you're usually separated and then of
course with the pandemic we were very
separated so there was really no ability
and usually when we see each other is
during the premiere um so i you know i'm
bummed that we're all separated this
time around but i know there's going to
be an allen family three i hope so at
least um so if there is
we'll we'll we'll have a good go at it
and uh maybe we'll all get together for
a little zoom cheers
yeah i hope so who would you say in your
family is the most excited to see this
film um
i mean my family we're such huge adams
family fans and you know i think my
brother colin probably is the most
excited he's like he's he's so into the
adam's family he loves animation as much
as i love animation so probably my
brother colin and my mother and my
brother trevor i mean all of them
honestly i could start naming the whole
family and my baby cousins
that's adorable
um what would you say is the biggest
challenge with voiceover work
um i think you know
getting the vocality correct i think
obviously that's the the biggest thing
about it all you have is your vocality
but you know really figuring out your
intonations and and and and how you know
different ranges of emotions come
through
um and especially with a character like
wednesday who is so predominantly uh
monotone
trying to figure out what sentimentality
sounds like um and and you know when
she's kind of taken aback i don't think
we've ever heard her
you know not be on the ball with
something so when something surprises
her
and she's taking that in it was really
an interesting thing to try and figure
out what that sounds like with her
vocality um
and it was you know it was fun it was a
little puzzle we tried to put puddles
together i love that thank you chloe
thanks everyone
thank you so much
you